[laughter]
>> Woah. So now, this action here, this
scholars need to be asked very simply,
is Andrew Tate still a Muslim?
Is he still a Muslim?
Brothers and sisters, just imagine for a
second that you give £10 in donation and
that £10 is used to buy food [music] or
bricks or whatever to help the people in
Gaza. But then just imagine this amazing
deed that you want to do, but we turn it
into a money-making machine. How?
The waqf is exactly [music] that. They
take your money and the money that we
are going to put in in this waqf, this
building, and every single time the
money generated from that waqf, that
building, is going to go to our
Palestinian brothers and sisters for the
next 20,
>> [music]
>> 30, 40, 50, 60, 100, 150 years. And this
will be a form of true sadaqah jariyah.
I myself will be donating for that,
inshallah. Click the link below and
donate. May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
bless and preserve you guys. As-salamu
alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh,
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Hope you guys are well, inshallah. So, I
came across this video of Andrew Tate
doing black magic.
>> [snorts]
>> Now, usually what I do is, guys,
subhanallah, I'll be honest with you. I
use scenarios of people doing stuff that
are stupid, dumb, or permissible,
whatever it is for that matter, and then
I try to give a reminder to everybody.
Usually that's what I do. So, some
people think that I'm trying to seek
drama. I'm not. I look at something and
say, "Okay, more peo- a lot of people do
not know." And he himself I've I've I've
lost all hope in Andrew Tate, with all
due respect. Okay, I I I I do not care
about him. But however, I use those
scenarios to show you guys and tell you
guys evidence from Islam in the Quran
and Sunnah. Here is a video of him in
Hong Kong. Because he went to Hong Kong
to do uh black magic, sihr, on Chinese
black magic and sihr on Ben Shapiro.
Now, we're going to come to the ruling
of this. What scholars say about this,
subhanallah. Can you use good for black
good uh black magic? Uh I mean, can you
use black magic to do good in the sense
Can I do black magic against Benjamin
Netanyahu?
Okay, we're going to be talking about
that. Uh if someone did black magic on
me, can I use black magic to get rid of
the black magic? Yes, is black magic
allowed in any way, shape, or form?
We're going to get into that. Before we
do, let's watch the video for ourselves
of him doing black magic on Ben Shapiro,
which uh potentially is kufr, is kufr,
can borderline maybe take him out of the
fold of Islam, but I can't make that
judgment. Uh but it's very dangerous.
Let's watch for ourselves and see what
he had to what he was doing.
What did we do?
Do you know why we actually came to Hong
Kong?
We came for ramen. No, we didn't. I told
you we came for ramen, but we actually
came for something far more important.
What did we really come to Hong Kong
for? What has the entire world been
waiting for? And as usual, I'm one to
[__] [__] and a [__] I have to get
it done. As usual, all the bad things
are happening, the Bat-Signal goes off,
Top G comes out, and has to fix
everything all by himself, cuz no one
else is [__] enough to get it done. As
usual, it's just me. What has the whole
world been waiting for?
I think it's actually
I analyzed studied geopolitics in my
spare time. I think it's for somebody to
put a Chinese curse on Ben Shapiro.
Correct. Thank you. We came to Hong Kong
to put a Chinese curse on Ben Shapiro.
And that's exactly what we're going to
do, because no one else is [__] doing
it. As usual, everyone else is just
standing around. So, we're going to have
to get this done. So, it turns out these
old ladies beating villains costs 50
Hong Kong dollars per person. Luckily,
in Hong Kong dollars, I'm literally a
[__] trillionaire. So, let's get it
done.
Who's going to get it? So so far, we're
going to come to inshallah. So far, as
you can see, uh to him it might have
sounded comedic, funny, joke, whatever
it is for that matter. This is a matter
of the deen. This is a matter of Islam.
It's about kufr, disbelief and belief.
This is something where,
you know, you have to speak out against
it. And um
to you know, to me, even if it's a joke,
like in any sense. We're going to come
to the ruling in a minute, so we're
going to read the
exactly what the scholars say about
this. But you can see, he's just in a
etc. as a joke, etc. In Islam, it
doesn't work like that, my friend. It
doesn't work like, "Oh, I'm just joking
around." No, kufr. This is a major,
major, major, major sin, bro. for Ben
Shapiro, please.
This is stupid.
All right, you can beat my villains?
Okay.
Sure.
He's a He's a villain. He's a bad guy.
We need to get rid of him.
What do I do?
Write his name.
All right, write his name.
All right, sure.
On the guy on the little figurine. Ben
This is a fair fight, though, because
Ben and her are about the same size.
Yeah. So, he can't complain.
Shapiro.
Shapiro. There you go, Ben Shapiro.
That's right, whoop his ass.
Yeah, that's right, I did it.
So cool. This is why we came to Hong
Kong.
>> why we came. This is exactly why.
Did it.
He'll never survive this.
They're the same They're the same size,
he can't complain.
>> [laughter]
>> Woah.
You'll feel like one of them Gaza kids
now.
Feel like a Ben.
See you, loser.
Thank you very much.
Okay, so uh let's get straight into
this. So, that joke that was made at the
end, it's I look, it's I'll be honest
with you.
Um I I don't I don't know what he means
by that, like, "Oh, now you're going to
feel like the Gaza kids."
Um
I mean, if you
if you really cared about those Gaza
kids, number one,
you would not have taken them in Israel.
Your girlfriends would not be Israelis.
Um and only that, it's not a joking
matter. I'll be honest with you, it's
not a joking matter. You'd be like those
Gaza kids, "Oh."
Those people have been massacred, man.
Those people have been gone through hell
on earth. I mean, just imagine if what
was done to them was done to your
daughters.
And I just said, "Oh, here Here we go.
Now you're going to suffer like Andrew
Tate's daughters."
You'd find it very deep- I mean, truly
speaking, bro, you'd come for me. You
would You would come for me. You would
want me dead. Maybe let's put it like
that, yeah? That's sickening within
itself. Now, you're going and doing
kufr. Now, we're going to go and read
what the scholars say about it, cuz in
the Quran and hadith, it's very clear.
The Prophet Sallallahu Alayhi Wasallam
said, "Those who are involved in black
magic, sihr, they are not from amongst
us."
Here's the question
uh that was asked.
Is it permissible to use witchcraft or
black magic for good purpose or stuff
like using it to convince your parents
about something like marriage or
someone? Here is the ruling. Okay.
Praise be to Allah and blessings of
peace be upon him on the messenger of
Allah. Witchcraft or magic is knowledge
that comes from the shayatin and is
something that they do. Allah says in
the interpretation of meaning, "They
followed what the shayatin, devils, gave
out falsely of the magic in the lifetime
of Sulaiman. Sulaiman did not
disbelieve, but shayatin, the devil,
disbelieved, teaching men magic." In
Surah Baqarah. This is the reason reason
why Allah says that Sulaiman didn't,
because you're thinking, "Of course he
didn't." No, cuz the Bible says he did.
The The Quran came to defend the honor
of the prophets, number one. "And they
learn from that which harms harms them
and profits them not. And indeed they
knew that the buyers of it, magic, would
have no share in the hereafter." Okay,
subhanallah. This is interesting. And
And indeed they know that the buyers of
it, magic, would have no share in the
hereafter. So, they know they can't use
it in the hereafter. But if someone
doesn't have grounded belief, that's
what Allah says in the Quran to the um
to the Bedouins. When they come and
said, "We believe." Allah said, "Don't
say you believe. Say you've submitted."
The only defense I can give Andrew Tate
is that, "Bro, you've become a Muslim."
Meaning, "You've submitted, but you iman
hasn't entered your heart, because
you're doing reckless stuff, bro." I've
seen pictures of you still like, "Oh,
yeah, I've got my life etc. with girls
and stuff like that." You're outwardly
you're a fasiq, doing open evil deeds.
And that's why we're calling you evil,
because you're an open evil doer. Now
you come and do magic like it's
happiness, okay? Now you can call this
haram because of whatever you like,
okay?
And this is what we do. We call out for
those feminist radical nifaqis who
think, "Oh, yeah." My friend, 70% of my
videos are against men, not that I pick
anyone, okay? Which is it debunks his
own claims anyway. The Prophet may peace
be upon him said, "Avoid seven sins
which doom a person to hell." They
asked, "What are they?" He said,
"Associating anyone with worship of
Allah, shirk, and witchcraft." And the
Prophet Muhammad, peace be peace and
blessing
of Allah be upon him, said, "He is not
one of us who practice witchcraft or has
it done for him." On the basis, it is
not permissible to use witchcraft for
any purpose whatsoever. Witchcraft or
magic is falsehood and all kinds of
falsehood and kufr are evil doing. Sin
cannot be a man's a means of achieving
something good. Beneficial things have
to be sought through the prescribed
means which involve no sin and whose
consequences are safe. Allah has given
his slaves sufficient means in the
things that he has permitted them. So,
they have no need for the things he has
he has forbidden. To him praise and
thanks for his blessings, subhanallah.
So, you can clearly see, that's the
reason why when the mushrikin would come
and say, "We're using the idols to get
close to Allah." The means don't justify
the ends. Okay? Okay? So, you need to
understand,
okay, that what? Just because you're
saying I'm getting close to Allah, you
can't come I can't come and say, "You
know what? I get close to Allah uh
argument say when I'm chilling with
girls or when I'm drinking alcohol or
when I'm selling uh when I'm doing
riba." You can't use something Allah has
prescribed to haram. You can't say,
"Personally to me, I just get close to
Allah, bro, when I'm just around, you
know, selling doing riba." No, it is
haram, it is impermissible. Now, the
thing here is this, this can take you
out of the fold of Islam. I'm not going
to do that. I'm not going to come and
say it's not my place to come and say.
And we've gone far beyond ignorance,
because you are obliged to study, like
Sneako is. Like Sneako, yeah, okay? And
like I said before, I'm not here like if
Andrew Tate is watching, I'm not I'm not
I I don't have a video to take on
anyone. Not Sneako or anyone, with all
due respect, okay? Sneako is our brother
and we defend him cuz he's our brother.
If Sneako steps out of line, I will do a
video against him. If I step out of
line, I would want Sneako to do a video
against me, reminding me and saying,
"Brother." Obviously private advice, but
if I went to Sneako and said, "Brother,
I'm so sorry." He has to It's obligated
on him. We don't believe this stupid,
dumb attitude of these nifaqi Muslim
women. Yeah, not all some of them, who
are like, "Oh, you can't call us out
because we're women." I don't give a
damn, bro, if you're a trans or a piano.
Identify as a tree, I don't care. Islam
has come and told us that we have to
enjoin goodness and forbid evil. So,
this attitude of, "Oh, you know, I
cannot refute this person because of
their gender" is nonsense. Whoever you
are, whatever you are, I don't care. If
you cross the boundaries of Islam, we
will come and do a video against you. So
now, this action here, this scholars
need to be asked very simply, is Andrew
Tate still a Muslim?
Is he still a Muslim? Because doing
these things different
>> [laughter]
>> Sihr is something that scholars say that
when you catch a sahir, yes? Okay?
Their repentance, even if they repent,
there's a capital punishment. Your
repentance between you and your Lord, no
problem. The capital punishment applies.
You are doing open sihr against you.
And then can you maybe in the Sharia
because Sheikh Uthaymeen has a book on
Islamic jurisprudence, maybe you can
come and say, "Look, I genuinely didn't
know."
But here, this is dangerous ground.
You're doing open sihr and recording
yourself like it's happy days. It is a
sin. You know why? It also shows you
don't have tawakkul in Allah. If you're
trusting in Allah, you will know that
Allah will
punish them. Allah says, "Don't ever
think I'm aware unaware of what the
evildoers do. I delay them for a day
their eyes will stare in horror." So to
have tawakkul and trust and patience is
what? I'm not going to go down the road.
And this applies to all of us, be it
marriage or this or that. When things
don't go your way, what do you want to
do? Sihr and fall into disbelief or
rather have belief in Allah and say,
"You know what? Allah has something best
planned. I'm not going to cross his
boundaries."
Think about that, brothers and sisters.
That's what I'm going to say. Inshallah,
till next time. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.